[Music]
it's time to tell my story seems like I
was born to struggle after a while I
guess I just lost hope that's when my
hair started falling out i'ma help you
my hair grow back and so did my
confidence maybe I could say you proud
of it
I don't paint sales is for you colored
women will do anything to look like me
even if deep down they know they can't I
can let you keep beating up on yourself
via now oh no doing my own hair make my
own hair gorilla come on Missy
I don't take orders no mo Lincoln freed
me 40 years back
that's why I'm gonna pay you and that's
why you my favorite daughter-in-law
let's talk about they put us down tell
us weirdly make us feel ugly wonderful
hair leads to wonderful opportunities
you sure are lucky you can call Makris
which is why I want my own factory
there's such a thing as growing too fast
we live in a man's foot it's just not
our place I didn't come here to make
sandwiches I came here to do business
oh no you won't do now sir I'm not going
back to long we don't all made
sacrifices you won't do what's best for
this family
yeah is beauty here is power damn Sarah
how big you want to be be Carnegie Ford
and Rockefeller put together
we got to work harder
be smarter
and dream big
[Music]